yeah but I yeah but I do do things that
I regret like you know I I did an
audition for this african-american black
you either one is fine I can black like
a black director I killed it in the
audition a years ago uh-huh and then he
goes stick around and talk and so I and
I was sat next to him and then um we
were talking and then he said words tell
me about your career this and that and I
for some reason we were laughing and I
poked him in the belly I go fatty like
that appropriate yeah so we were like
you know he says we I don't forgot what
we're laughing about we're like and I
was in the moment yeah like that and I
poked him really hard in the stomach and
then what and and he just
okay thank you oh my god that's so and I
walked out of the audition and in my
head I was like but here's the thing and
this is one of the reasons why I do that
a lot I know but this is why and I've
said this before I think I said it on
this podcast last time I was here one of
my favorite things about you yeah is
that you are the same way to everybody
that is a very very cool thing that most
people are not and that means that you
have a solid idea of who you are and
you're gonna be you no matter what
because if you met Barack Obama you'd be
like you would you would you'd be like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy but
you'd like you yeah but it only works
though if you know who I am like if you
like you like it because you know who I
am but imagine yeah never and being
knowing me yeah and then me acting like
that but then people call me I've had
people call me he's eccentric yeah but
it's still a good thing I think
yeah because you're a good guy you're
not an [ __ ] if you're an [ __ ]
right different do that make you mad
like not texting you back yeah but
that's a quirk that's better about it
since you were on here last um no maybe
a little bit yeah yeah maybe a little
bit I mean you do call me out on that
you know in public yup in front of other
people yeah cuz I don't want them to
feel bad that you're not texting them
back rah would be like listen he does it
to me too and I'm wondering I like when
you do that yeah well okay yeah yeah
change it though No okay I won't change
it because the thing is is that when you
tell other people yeah like I have like
you know people that are below not below
but in career gum scum watch or the worm
right yeah I touched you about doing my
belly room show right yeah but I just
don't text back and then you'll come in
and go who you are Yeah right so
annoying it's fun it's annoying yes I'm
Barack Obama be like why don't you text
me back yeah but you know what um I've
been trying to get better about it like
there's really no trying you just you
just [ __ ] text back you just see the
message and you go Buddha Li boop boop
said that's it there's no trying okay
I'm gonna give you I'm going okay I'm
gonna look at my insta might and I'm
like my texts
okay I don't tell you people who'd like
I'll give you an example all right Eric
Griffin okay he goes um 6:30 all things
let me know hey [ __ ] face
Wednesday 6:30 and I wait 24 hours right
and I just put okay okay now when you
got the tax yeah when did you get that
because he would when did you get the
tax is what I'm asking and that's all
I'm asking 24 hours in advance
you got the text pay man when did you
receive the text and then see it
yesterday and you saw it yesterday yes
and then you think what oh I see what
you're saying yeah why yeah
what here's a think when you see it
right this is the first because it you
know how they do three in a row
all right yeah he goes Wednesday 6 3 all
things all things means all things
combined oh so he's just exclamation
mark part when I read that at first I
got nah because he's being he's being
too aggressive Wow
right so I go I'm not gonna respond to
that Wow right and then the second wow
let me know are you his girlfriend goes
let me know ok I don't like it really
because you just did our podcast last
week he goes hey [ __ ] Wednesday 6:30
there you go now he's getting angry
that's good so thank ok yeah ok so you
want a guy to be very angry at you but
not aggressive yeah yeah I just want it
to be a certain way you know a man
interesting like a [ __ ] world huh
yeah the who like today mm-hm 8:45 a.m.
hmm are you around yeah yeah Matt Blake
okay my age oh Jesus crying okay you got
a [ __ ] right because 20 text messages
in there how many have you replied to
okay agent my agent nothing nothing
nothing nothing
why I have a gift for you often this guy
what time is your spot tonight nothing
no nothing he's your [ __ ] I know
because he's a nice guy I love him he's
my brother
but do you know why I do that uh-huh
because um if it was serious about
business yeah I know you're looking at
your watch no no no I know you're very
busy baby all right but the reason why
is if it's business it'll go through my
ABI
okay Abby I'll go you have an audition
or they wanted to see you on tape or
something something something right when
he texts is it's gonna be like him
venting oh yeah Oh Gabriel Iglesias I
know what happened so and so whatever
what happens me right made up you don't
have I know yeah he doesn't have a thing
I'm just giving you an example Jesus
Christ or like when he was here up Bill
Cosby mm-hmm do you know that uh who's
that yeah anyway yeah but Bill Cosby
doing the thing right
the ripen yeah when I say the thing is
the right thing yeah right he was just
like I don't know what to do this is
[ __ ] inside you know me and there's a
friend so if you any I love you if you
don't if you don't respond them because
you don't want to be there for a friend
no no that's not what it is is this it
right now I don't feel great and I
should I'm gonna take them back to
tomorrow text them now
[Music]